jetzt geht es um überhang und
ausgleichsmandaten was ist das
eigentlich die zweitstimme die ist
entscheidend für die
mehrheitsverhältnisse im bundestag aber
manchmal da passiert ist dass durch die
erststimme mehr kandidaten in den
bundestag gelangen als der partei gemäss
zweitstimmen zustehen und dann kommt es
zu sogenannten überhangmandaten und das
ist der effekt der den bundestag immer
größer werden lässt die partei darf
nämlich alle zusätzlichen sitze behalten
und damit die anderen parteien nicht
benachteiligt werden gibt es sogenannte
ausgleichsmandaten die stellen das
kräfteverhältnis wieder her und diese
parteien können dann auch zusätzliche
sitze bekommen wie das im detail
berechnet wird es ist fürchterlich
kompliziert und deswegen gibt es und gab
es immer streit über ausgleichs und
überhangmandate